now the question is will our friend
novak djokovic
step up to condemn these recent violent
threats and propagations against muslims
from these served nationalist christian
techniques whatever you call them
alleged supporters attacked and shot at
a mosque in the town of yanya
police in berkshire district also had
their hands full while across the border
in serbia's pre-boy and novi pazar there
were threats of ethnic violence
who are threatening to shoot mass what
is this
look to make you happy novak we'll go
first as muslims and i'm sure the muslim
community in bosnia would unequivocally
condemn any acts and threats like this
on churches or christians as you know
during the war
all churches were protected and
safeguarded according to islam the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
prophet muhammad peace and blessed be
upon him
but the mosques were leveled to the
ground not spirit at all you know this
novak djokovic and i've seen it
firsthand so threats like these should
be swiftly called out and condemned
and your silence is your complicitness
my friend so you need to speak out
all good people need to speak out
against such behavior otherwise just
look at all the mobs look what's
happening this is unacceptable
knowing the history in the region what
the people went through
there is no excuse
nobody should be inciting this type of
violent hate provoking with threats of
violence towards the mosque and innocent
human beings in an already extremely
fragile intense atmosphere in bosnia
people of influence like novak djokovic
have to speak up but will you speak up
novak or remain silent after you see
this message and inshallah god willing
this message will get to you now who's
novak djokovic he's a very famous
serbian tennis player he's been all over
the news recently for his stance on
natural immunity but that's not what
we're going to be talking about here
today the top-ranked men's player in the
world novak djokovic controversy
surrounding the top-ranked player in
men's tennis the champ
remains in detention in melbourne this
morning djokovic's legal team stating
that he was granted a visa back in
november without qualification for his
vaccination status also that he was
infected with kova 19 in recent weeks he
tested positive for kovid on december
16th on which he was photographed
unmasked at an event in his native
serbia we're calling on one of the most
famous and influential persons in that
part of the world and in the tennis
community novak djokovic others like him
the scholars the christian authority to
speak up against what's going on in
bosnia and serbia we've had enough of
this kind of talk from the past
and this guy's the president supposedly
he's also a christian what is this the
good people out there from all
communities have to stand up against
this type of evil behavior muslims are
held to account for any mad lunatic who
might somehow be connected to islam or
says salams like no vector novak
these are the type of huge double
standards the muslim community has to go
through but before and now you still
have people celebrating convicted war
criminals serbia is riding a wave of
neo-nationalism
the difference here is that the
movement's role models are convicted war
criminals men with violent pasts whose
acts of aggression are not just excused
but publicly glorified who were
practicing christianity getting their
guns blessed by the church while you had
the worst atrocities in evil committed
brothers and sisters if you didn't know
you can go ahead and look this up why
this is so dangerous
as you had the recent christ church
terrorists and andrew brevik also they
were inspired by these same terrorists
and war criminals who frankly hide
behind christianity but it's all
connected the shooter covered his weapon
with the names of far right role models
as he drove to a mosque in christchurch
he played a traditional serbian military
song and he cited convicted serb war
criminal radivan karajic in his
manifesto
and he's not the only one serbian
nationalists have inspired other white
supremacists including anders breivik
who killed 77 people in norway in 2011.
but you have never heard the media ever
bring up their religion
so novak you're a christian
to all the
orthodox christians i wish them peace
love
who would probably say he believes in
one god
in peace and love peace love so we're
going to hold you to that if you really
do come speak up against what's going on
in bosnia
and we invite you on the dean show to do
your part so we could do our part to
helps put a stop to these threats on
mass and muslims
in your country and in bosnia before
these things get way out of control so
let's get in touch novak djokovic and
help us stop this evil and do more good
in the world my friend nadine show
audience you guys can do your part go
ahead if you knew that this is going to
help
to
do some good by you just liking the
video and inshallah this can go ahead
and possibly by you sharing also this
can get to novak djokovic so we can go
ahead and do our small part go ahead
like the video share it
and so you don't miss out make sure you
subscribe hit that notification bell so
we can keep you updated hopefully we can
get novak djokovic on the show he steps
up so we can help to put a stop
to what's going on
in bosnia before this gets way out of
control until next time brothers and
sisters peace be with you assalamu
alaikum thank you guys for tuning in
make sure that you like this video and
if you're going to get rewarded every
time you put the like on one of our
videos because inshaallah there's much
benefit behind it can do some good and
you get rewarded you'd like it so go
ahead and hit the like button
leave your comments
in the comments below if you have
particular topics that you'd like to see
us cover go ahead and share that with us
and you got this video here you can
watch and another one here and make sure
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you don't miss out on any
up and coming episodes that come out see
you next time peace be with you assalamu
alaikum